norm mcdonald has died he was 61. i do
the weekend update you know the fake
news i might return to my first love
dance
i don't know the saturday night live
veteran's death on tuesday follows a
nine-year battle with cancer a struggle
that he had decided to keep private
after the news broke mcdonald's comedy
peers took to social media with their
heartfelt tributes that's a little scoop
for the viewers
jim carrey wrote on twitter my dear
friend norm mcdonald passed away after a
brave 10-year battle he was one of our
most precious gems an honest and
courageous comedy genius i love him i
know this job looks easy it does look
easy
conan o'brien shared norm had the most
unique comedic voice i have ever
encountered sarah silverman told her
fans please do yourself a favor and
watch his stuff he was one of a kind
hey check out the podium look at this mr
reynolds has apparently changed his name
to turd ferguson
the comedian was well known for his time
on saturday night live including three
seasons at the weekend update desk well
a study this week reports seafood is
good for you unless it's fried
yet another groundbreaking story from
the pages of the medical journal duh
[Music]